it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases and this week love it
or not so love it we're getting the new
Star Fox for Wii U the game is
controlled using the Wii U gamepad with
the left control stick used to maneuver
the craft while gyroscopic controls can
be used to aim weapons a cockpit view is
displayed on the gamepad screen to
assist with aiming various elements
return from previous games including
foxes teammates Falco peppy and slippy
who can assist the player by protecting
them from enemy attacks some of the
games vehicles can transform in certain
situations for example the arwing can
transform into the walker a new vehicle
introduced into the series is the gyro
wing a drone like helicopter which can
lower a small robot that can enter small
spaces and hack into computers there's a
lot of new here and if you want to try
and mix your nostalgia with some brand
new Wii U gamepad and gameplay mechanics
you can start piloting on the 22nd do a
barrel roll also this week a tremendous
tactical RPG gets a long-awaited sequel
it's Banner Saga to continue your
journey soon after the climactic events
of the original banner saga and the
choices you made in the first game will
affect who's alive and who is not as the
world continues to crumble around you
only one bastion of hope remains but
getting there will require strong
leadership hard sacrifices influencing
new heroes and as always sound strategy
in combat most importantly you get an
excuse to have more beautifully 2d
hand-drawn combat sequences and
animations accompanied by music from
Austin wintry I mean come on go get it
you become a thunder Slayer on the 19th
speedrunners is sprinting out early
access this week it's a cutthroat
multiplayer running game that pits four
players against each other locally and
or online it's a nice mix of skill from
running and jumping with agility while
items you pick up like missiles mines
and grappling hooks can really mix
things up a bit you can think of it like
mario kart but on foot it is fun run
like the wind on the 19th battlefleet
gothic Armada is the RTS video game
adaptation of games workshop's classic
tabletop game pitting the chaos Imperium
eldar and orcs against each other in
visceral space battles an expansive
single-player campaign across the gothic
sector is yours along with four factions
to command each one with its own
strengths and skills there's also an
extensive multiplayer mode with
persistent fleets were up to four
players can battle simultaneously it
looks impressive and if you're
interested in this space RTS you can
pick your faction on the 21st finally
get your hands on indie Metroidvania
style axiom verge on PS vita already own
it on ps4 you say well now you can have
it on Vita for free because it's
cross-buy good on you Tom have for
following through the promise made over
a year ago explore and uncover the
mystery of a surreal alien world by
blasting aliens and glitching your
environment in this intense retro
side-scrolling action adventure that's
absolutely worth your time it's gorgeous
dust off your Vita on the 19th do you
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings sometimes they change
I can't help that we do our best get
some of these awesome games I will see
you now